wouldn't you rather see a version of Ron
who's willing to stand on a broken leg
to protect Harry or a visit to Saint
mungo's hospital for a magical malady's
in full color this is everything we want
to see in the new Harry Potter series
if there's one thing we can all agree on
it's this the original cast was pretty
incredible we had acting Legends like
Alan Rickman playing Snape and Maggie
Smith as Professor McGonagall so it's
going to be pretty hard to find talent
that moves us beyond that for the HBO
series hard but not impossible we're
hoping to find a cast that's able to
bring their own spin to these characters
but still understands what it is that we
loved about them in the first place and
although we can't wait to see what a new
team brings we're also hoping to see
some cameos from the original cast maybe
an actor who was given one role in the
movies can play another in the HBO
series like Helena Bonham Carter playing
ant petunia or something all of this
would go a long way towards making the
HBO series feel like its own thing
giving us an entirely new take on a few
familiar characters would you believe us
if we said that Ron was a great wizard
in the books he truly is please yes but
the movies decided to make him comic
relief for some reason you'll be Panic
now his heroic moments were more often
than not given to Hermione like when he
stands on a broken leg to protect Harry
from serious and Prisoner of Azkaban
instead Hermione does this in the movie
he wants to kill Harry you'll have to
kill off too nobody really knows why
this change was made although some have
suggested that it could have something
to do with screenwriter Steve cloves
admitting that Hermione was his favorite
character whether or not this is true
we're still hoping to see a more book
accurate version of Ron in the HBO
series this is HBO's chance to give us
an entirely new Wizarding World the
first two Harry Potter movies were
filled with so much magic in color from
the Reds and Golds on the Gryffindor
House scarves to the greens of the
quidditch field everything seemed alive
until suddenly it got real drab real
quick let's be real here the color
scheme on the movies only gets darker
and darker by the sequel and as much as
that definitely suits the tone it's
something that has bothered fans for
years just like all those unused
subplots that they dropped from the book
this HBO series is the perfect chance to
give us an entirely new take on how the
Wizarding World can look kind of like
how this is your perfect chance to hit
that subscribe button if you're enjoying
our video it's possible we may get all
the bright colors and Whimsical tones of
the first two Harry Potter movies back
or the HBO series might give us a
version that's entirely new in either
case we'll be getting new Hogwarts robes
new Death Eaters and even a new Diagon
Alley there were so many great moments
from the books that never even made it
into the movies remember how much they
explored Voldemort's backstory in the
Half Blood Prince or that time Harry
visits St Mongo's Hospital for Magical
maladies in order of the Phoenix and we
got to learn a lot more about Neville
and even visit with gilderoy Lockhart
one last time well yes um there were
plenty of moments that either told us a
lot more about the world or about the
characters in it that the movie simply
cut for time this HBO Max series is
going to have a lot more of a chance to
dive into these unused subplots and we
hope that we get to see them take full
advantage of it but it isn't only
subplots from the books that got
forgotten by the movies either its
entire characters do you remember peeps
the Poltergeist if you do then you've
probably read the books peeves never
even appeared in the movies not one
despite being in literally every Harry
Potter novel there is out there he was a
bit of a trickster Poltergeist who
haunted the halls of Hogwarts and was
always getting on filchust nerves in one
way or another fans were excited to see
his Antics on the big screen back in the
day when the books were first adapted
but they were sorely dismayed to see
that important moments like the one when
peeves tormented Dolores Umbridge at the
end of Harry Potter and the Order of
Phoenix were completely written out of
the movies we are so hoping to see
peeves make it into the HBO series in
one way or another even if it's just a
passing nod to the way he would get
under Village's skin but then again
there are main characters in this series
who we are still hoping will get more
than the bare minimum from an adaptation
Ron wasn't the only Weasley Done Dirty
by the movies our next character may
have been written out entirely sure but
the books revealed Ginny to be a
firecracker she starts out with a crush
on Harry Jenny she's been talking about
your summer
that's annoying really but eventually
grows past that and finds herself as a
star quidditch player it's only once she
comes into herself that Harry starts to
return her feelings in the movies we get
none of that Arc we see hints that Ginny
plays quidditch but those moments are
few and far between she's just sort of
passive in the movies making it really
hard for us to understand what Harry
likes about her in the books there's no
question about it she's a powerful witch
who knows how to handle herself on and
off the quidditch field and that's the
version of Ginny we'd love to see in
this new HBO series do you know which
chapter is rumored to be JK Rowling's
favorite it's called the other minister
and it's a moment in the Half-Blood
Prince where the minister for magic
Cornelius fudge visits with the Mughal
prime minister just to update him on
what Voldemort's been up to this scene
was replaced with one that had the Death
Eaters destroying a bridge in the Muggle
world in the movie which just doesn't
have the same oomph the original
characters made us feel like The
Wizarding World was so well connected
did with our own and although we'd like
to see some new material too this
chapter just has to make it onto the HBO
series we'd be willing to wait six
seasons to see it happen if we're
following JK Rowling's original timeline
here then that would make John Major the
British head of government any chance we
can get Johnny Lee Miller in seeing as
he's already played Major on the crown
the rules turned upside down for a day
it isn't only the moments from the books
we're excited to see in the HBO series
we're excited for the scenes that will
be new to the series altogether up until
now everything we've seen from Harry
Potter has followed his point of view
pretty perfectly meaning that we haven't
really gotten all too many moments where
Harry isn't present if this HBO series
is going to be anything like some of the
other children's book adaptations we've
seen as of late Like A Series of
Unfortunate Events then chances are
we're going to be getting a few moments
that explore the perspective of some of
the other characters maybe we'll have a
personal moment with Dumbledore or
perhaps we'll catch up with what the
ministry of magic is doing in either
case we can't wait to see see it and we
hope that these moments give us a new
view on some old characters perhaps even
ones that we've never even thought we
could feel before the dursleys always
seem to get the short end of the stick
but maybe that's because they're Muggles
and Muggles aren't as interesting as The
Wizarding World right you are Harry no
post on Sunday the Books open up on a
scene that has Uncle Vernon walking
around town after Voldemort has been
defeated noticing how the entire magical
world has been not so subtly celebrating
it's moments like this that would really
help to add a certain air of
individuality and book authenticity to
the HBO series we'd also like to see
more character development from the
dursleys like what we got to see in the
books a deleted scene from the movies
shows a more human side to the dursleys
where they say goodbye to Harry but
again that scene was deleted I don't
think you're always to space we'd love
to see more moments like this in the HBO
series just to show us a new side of the
characters between subplots that never
had their chance to fully shine in the
original movies to full characters that
were dropped entirely you've finally
done it you've finally driven him loopy
there's still plenty of new material for
the Harry Potter series to work with
which moments from the books are you
most excited to see the series handle
and is there anything new you'd like to
see done make sure to let us know in the
comment section down below
[Music]